اعتقد الناس لفترة طويلة في
الشرق الأوسط أنه ما لم تتمكن من
القيام بأي شيء بشأن القضية الفلسطينية
في القضية الإسرائيلية الفلسطينية ،
فلن تتمكن من تحقيق السلام مع العرب
وفي الواقع ما فعلته كان عكس
ذلك جيدًا أنت و ال  دول الخليج
بمعنى ما الذي تعتقد أنه تغير هو أن
القضية الفلسطينية قد تراجعت للتو
في أهميتها بالنسبة لـ abs لأنه كان
هناك وقت تعرفه بالتأكيد عندما
تعود إلى عبد الناصر والناس بهذه الطريقة
كانت القضية المركزية أو هي
إن صعود إيران قد منح إسرائيل
والمملكة العربية السعودية والإمارات العربية المتحدة عدوًا مشتركًا
، أعتقد أنه في نفس الوقت صعود إيران
وصعود إسرائيل ، فقد كرست
جزءًا كبيرًا من حياتي وكل
حياتي البالغة لتعزيز جيش إسرائيل
القوة التي لا يمكن تعزيزها إلا من خلال
تحرير اقتصاداتها ، لدينا
قوة اقتصادية ومزيج
من الاثنين أعطانا القوة الثالثة التي هي
القوة الدبلوماسية عندما
أصبحت إسرائيل  إن لم تكن
الدولة الرائدة في مجال الابتكار التي أنتجت
الآلاف من الشركات الناشئة التي
أنتجت الأمن
السيبراني أنتجت معلومات استخباراتية لا مثيل لها ضد
الإرهاب ، فقد أصبحنا مثار اهتمام لدول أخرى
في خمس قارات ولكن أيضًا
في الشرق الأوسط وعندما قادت بصراحة
معارضة تسليح إيران لنفسها
بأسلحة نووية  خلق
مصلحة مشتركة مع العديد من الدول العربية
فتصاعد جو
التهديد الإيراني من جهة
وصعود القوة الإسرائيلية من جهة أخرى
مجتمعة لأعتقد أن تخلق أه
مصلحة في دول الخليج التي الآن
لم ينظروا إلى إسرائيل على أنها عدوهم ، بل هي
حليفهم الذي لا غنى عنه لمواجهة
الخيط المشترك إيران وأيضًا
لتحسين حياة مواطنيهم من خلال
الابتكار والتكنولوجيا الإسرائيلي ،
ما الذي تعتقد أنه سيستغرقه من المملكة
العربية السعودية للانضمام إلى عملية التطبيع تلك
التي من الواضح أنك تحاول  للحصول عليه
ورأى التقرير أنهم يريدون بعض
التحرك بشأن القضية الإسرائيلية الفلسطينية ،
فما الذي يتطلبه الأمر للحصول على
تعترف المملكة العربية السعودية بإسرائيل جيدًا ، فإن
أول شيء يجب أن تعترف به هو
أن المملكة العربية السعودية قد بدأت بالفعل
عملية تطبيع متزايدة
لأنه في عام 2018 قبل اتفاق أبراهام بفترة
طويلة في عام 2020 ، فتح السعوديون
مجالهم الجوي السعودي لمئات
الآلاف من الإسرائيليين الذين  يمكن أن تسافر إلى
دول الخليج والآن خارج دول الخليج ،
وكان ذلك قرارًا متعمدًا
أيضًا لأكون صادقًا ، ولا أعتقد أنني
أكشف هنا شيئًا لا تعرفه ،
لكنني سأقوله على أي حال ، لا توجد
طريقة  كانت الاتفاقات مع دول الخليج
لتحدث دون
موافقة السعودية ، لذا فإن المملكة العربية السعودية
تشق طريقها ببطء نحو أه التطبيع
أعتقد أن هذا على الطريق الذي
سيكون بالتأكيد هدفي الرئيسي الدبلوماسي
إذا أعيد انتخابي كما آمل.
سيكون في غضون أسابيع قليلة أعتقد أنهم يجب
أن يكون لديهم الثقة
بأن إسرائيل مستمرة في سياسة
أه في مواجهة العدوان الإيراني
الذي يهددهم أه ليس بنفس القدر ولكن
ليس أقل بكثير  هل هذا
يهددنا وأعتقد أنهم سيضمنون ذلك
إذا أعيد انتخابي ، فأنت لا تعتقد أنهم
سيتطلبون أي تحرك بشأن
القضية الإسرائيلية الفلسطينية ربما البعض
ولكن أعتقد أنهم يدركون أيضًا أنه
إذا أعطيت  الفلسطينيون فيتو
لن نحصل على السلام دعني
أسألك عن الصفقة الإيرانية التي كنت
مؤثراً جداً في إقناع دونالد ترامب
بالانسحاب من الصفقة الإيرانية
في ذلك الوقت أه والهيئة وحتى
المخابرات الإسرائيلية لذا الجميع أه
يعتقد أن إيران كانت ملتزمة
بالاتفاق وكان على بعد حوالي عام
ونصف من القدرة على صنع سلاح نووي
الآن بعد أن تم إلغاء الصفقة.
سلاح نووي
كيف يعمل ذلك على تعزيز أمن
إسرائيل لتكون في وضع
لا توجد فيه قيود لإيران على
ما تفعله وقد كثفت أه
كل المسارات إلى القنبلة النووية
جيدًا التي أصفها في كتابي للقراءة
غارة س  في الأرشيفات النووية الإيرانية السرية
التي فوضت الموساد
بتنفيذها ، وإذا رأيت هل شاهدت
فيلم Argo ، فقد رأيت أن
هذا كان هدفنا على المنشطات أعني
رجالنا أه بيلفورد أه من خزائن مقفلة
أه نصف طن من المواد  أقراص أه
الوثائق وكانوا يطاردونهم من قبل
الأمن الإيراني ، قاموا
بإخراجها ، وعندما نظرنا
إلى هذه المواد ، استطعنا أن نرى أن إيران
كانت تكذب لأنها لم تلتزم
بالاتفاقية في الواقع ، ثم ذهبنا إلى هيئة الطاقة
الذرية  مع ثلاثة مواقع ، ثلاثة
مواقع نووية لم يصرحوا بها ، لذا
كانت إيران تغش ، ولم تكن الصفقة تحمي
بأي شكل من الأشكال ، ونعم باتفاق أو
بدون اتفاق ، ستمضي إيران قدمًا في
تطوير أسلحة نووية ، الشيء الوحيد
الذي يوقف نظامًا مارقًا  من
تطوير أسلحة نووية وأقول
هذا على وجه التحديد في كتابي هو
مزيج من العقوبات المعوقة
وخيار عسكري ذي مصداقية ، فكل ما
يفعله فريد هو أن يعطي إيران
ختمًا دوليًا أه بالموافقة على
ecome a a threshold state النووووووووووووووووول
يدرك الجميع أن الصفقة
لن تمنع إيران ولن
تمنع ترسانة نووية
بل ستسهلها بموافقة دولية ،
لا يمكنك تجنب
حقيقة أنه يتعين عليك مواجهة إيران